“I reckon ‘Yesterday’ is
probably my best song.
I like it not only because it was a big success,
but because it was one of the most instinctive
songs I’ve ever written.
I was so proud of it.
I felt it was an original tune- the most complete
thing I’ve ever written.
It’s very catchy without being sickly”-
Paul McCartney.
“Yesterday”, written entirely (or almost
entirely– read on) by Paul McCartney, is
either the most, or second most, recorded
song of all-time.
(Guinness World Records claimed it was the
most, but this has been contested with others
claiming George Gershwin’s 1935 “Summertime”
is the true owner of that mantle.)
Whatever the case, to date, at least 4,000
different versions of the classic “Beatles”
tune have been recorded by artists as diverse
as Frank Sinatra, Elvis Presley, Liberace,
Tammy Wynette, Daffy Duck (!), The Mamas and
the Papas, Marvin Gaye, Ray Charles and Placido
Domingo.
In the mid-sixties, long before “Yesterday”
was known to the general public, singer Billy
J. Kramer said he was looking for a new song
to record and Paul played him “Yesterday.”
Poor Billy turned it down because he said
it wasn’t right for him.
Chris Farlowe also turned down the number,
telling Paul, “It’s not for me.
It’s too soft.
I need a good rocker, a shuffle or something.”
So how did Paul come up with it?
“It was the only song I ever dreamed,”
said McCartney.
Yep, the tune for “Yesterday” came to
Paul McCartney in a dream.
Paul woke up one morning, late in 1963 in
the attic bedroom of Jane Asher’s house
(Jane was his then-girlfriend) with a complete
melody in his head and set some nonsense lyrics
to it.
The original title was actually “Scrambled
Eggs.” Paul’s original lyrics were, “Scrambled
eggs, Oh you’ve got such lovely legs, Scrambled
eggs.
Oh, my baby, how I love your legs.”
As for the tune, Paul was initially unsure
whether he had actually thought it up himself
or if he had unintentionally stolen it from
another composer.
He played the tune to the other Beatles and
recalled, “It was like handing in something
you’d found at the police station and waiting
to see if anyone claimed it.”
Still unsure, Paul played the melody to several
other musicians and composers, but each one
assured him they didn’t recognize it and
he hadn’t unintentionally stolen it from
another source.
After its ultimate release and widespread
popularity with no one claiming the tune,
in every McCartney interview since 1980, Paul
has claimed complete 100% authorship and ownership
of the song.
But, as with so many “facts” in the history
of the Beatles, this now-gospel is disputed.
According to John C. Winn, author of the excellent
Beatles book “That Magic Feeling: The Beatles
Recorded Legacy,” when Paul first played
the song to his fellow Beatles, it was John
who suggested the three-syllable title “Yesterday.”
In a pre-1980 interview, John also stated:
“The song was around for months and months
before we completed it.”
(Note the “we”.)
Lennon continued, in the same interview: “Paul
wrote nearly all of it.
We just couldn’t find the right title.”
In an interview in March of 1967, Paul also
stated John came up with the title when asked
by Brian Matthew about the backstory of “Yesterday.”
John stated, “Ah well, this is John saying
I don’t know anything about that one.
I’ll hand you over to Paul.”
Paul then stated, “This is Paul, taking
up the story in a holiday villa in Corsica.
Strumming away on a medieval guitar, I thought
[sings] ‘Scrambled Egg.’
But I never could finish it, and eventually
I took it back in.
With the ancient wisdom of the east, John
came out with [sings] ‘Yesterday’.”
This is in direct contradiction to a May of
1965 interview in which Paul stated, “I
remember mulling over the tune ‘Yesterday’,
and suddenly getting these little one-word
openings to the verse.
I started to develop the idea … da-da da,
yes-ter-day, sud-den-ly, fun-il-ly, mer-il-ly
and Yes-ter-day, that’s good.
All my troubles seemed so far away.
It’s easy to rhyme those a’s: say, nay,
today, away, play, stay, there’s a lot of
rhymes and those fall in quite easily, so
I gradually pieced it together from that journey.
Sud-den-ly, and ‘b’ again, another easy
rhyme: e, me, tree, flea, we, and I had the
basis of it.”
By 1980, John had also changed his tune, saying
in his Playboy interview that “Yesterday”
was entirely Paul’s and that he had nothing
whatsoever to do with it.
“I never wished I’d written it and I don’t
believe in Yesterday.”
Whether or not “Yesterday” is indeed 100%
Paul’s song or whether John helped in any
way with it joins the scores of other “Mysteries
of the Beatles” that will undoubtedly remain
a bit baffling and will be “unsolved completely”
for the ages.
But if we’re not nitpicking, it seems clear
it was a “Paul work,” with a possible
extremely minor contribution from John.
In the end, it took almost two full years
for “Yesterday” to be recorded after the
original “Scrambled Eggs” version.
According to Beatles producer George Martin,
Paul first played the song for him in Paris
in January of 1964 and told him he thought
the title “Yesterday” might be “too
corny,” but Martin assured him it was not.
It was finally recorded officially in June
of 1965.
At first, they tried different ideas, including
with John playing the organ, but eventually
everyone decided it should be a Paul solo.
Thus, “Yesterday” became the first-ever
“Beatle” song recorded with only one Beatle
and one Beatle alone.
The other “evolutionary” factor in the
recording was the bringing in of a string
quartet to back up Paul on the song.
This was quite a huge breakthrough at the
time for a mere “pop record.”
These two factors were not without minor repercussions-
jealousy from the other Beatles.
(“Yesterday” was to be an early indicator
of the chinks in the armor of early Beatle
unity.)
“Yesterday” was released on the Beatles
“Help!” album in 1965.
The song wasn’t released as a single in
Britain until after the band had officially
split up (the “Yesterday as a single”
idea was vetoed by John, George and Ringo.)
George Martin knew it was a “Paul song”
and thought it should be released as such.
But Beatles’ manager Brian Epstein quickly
put the kibosh on this idea: “No.
It is the Beatles.”
According to Martin: “He did not want to
divide his holy quartet.
Though it wasn’t the Beatles at all, it
had to remain so, as part of their recordings.
I don’t think it irritated Paul at the time
because he considered himself a Beatle above
all other things.”
True, John did reap one-half of the composing
royalties from “Yesterday” although it
was “Paul’s baby,” but very shortly
thereafter, Paul would reap the same one-half
from songs completely written by John (“Strawberry
Fields Forever,” “Come Together,” “I
Am The Walrus,” “Revolution,” and many
others.)
When the Beatles began touring in June of
1965, Paul initially didn’t play “Yesterday”
because he thought it might upset John.
This changed when the Beatles appeared on
“Blackpool Night Out” in August of 1965.
Apparently Paul was right and John didn’t
like this “solo spot” idea and made sarcastic
remarks all through Paul’s rehearsals of
the song.
(As an interesting sidebar, at the “Blackpool
Night Out” performance, Paul reportedly
dedicated the song to his ex-girlfriend, Iris
Caldwell.
Other sources claim Iris had once called Paul
“unemotional” and he called Iris up and
played “Yesterday” to her over the phone
to prove otherwise.)
On August 14, 1965, Paul performed the song
on “The Ed Sullivan Show”- when he finished
the number, John Cuttingly said, “Thank
you Paul, that was just like him.”
George was later to complain, “Blimey!
He’s always talking about that song.
You’d think he was Beethoven or somebody.”
Despite the other Beatles’s derision, Paul
was to perform the song solo at many of their
live concerts during their 1965-66 tours.
Of course, the Beatles all sang a drunk-like,
sarcastic version of the song on their 1965
Christmas record.
Even the great Bob Dylan joined the anti-
“Yesterday” chorus, saying, “If you
go to the library of congress you can find
a lot better songs than that… there are
millions of songs like ‘Michelle’ and
‘Yesterday’ written in tin pan alley.”
(Ironically, Dylan was to record his own version
of the song four years later.
It was never released.)
Despite the puerile jealousies of his friends
and colleagues, “Yesterday” remains a
classic, easily the best-known and most beloved
of Paul McCartney’s legions of compositions-
his “signature song,” which has been heaped
with numerous accolades.
For instance, in 1997, “Yesterday” was
inducted into the Grammy Hall of Fame.
It was also voted the best song of the 20th
century in a BBC 2 poll of music experts and
listeners.
MTV and Rolling Stone Magazine also named
it the #1 pop song of all-time.
Broadcast Music Incorporated (BMI) asserts
that “Yesterday” was performed over 7
million times in the 20th century alone.
Not bad for a song whose tune came to the
composer in a dream and that started out with
the lyrics, “Scrambled eggs, Oh you’ve
got such lovely legs, Scrambled eggs.
Oh, my baby, how I love your legs.”